describe your style in three words
simple
competent and casual
that fits you in kind thank you what is
something you would never wear nothing I
think that I am absolutely open to
absolutely everything there's nothing
that I fear wearing and there's nothing
that's an absolute no if you send me a
message in 12 years and say Gary I think
you should really wear bow ties because
now 12 years from now we're friends
because now we met and we're gonna be
friends forever and I would be like okay
so like I am always in the business of
maybe I have no nose so the answer is
there's nothing I wouldn't wear
right yeah I would wear everything